this video has been an express request
from all members of the visualpolitik
community on patreon so it's
particularly dedicated to all of you
once again thank you so much and a
million thanks for supporting this
project and for those of you who are not
patreon members and want more
information we'll leave you a link in
the description let's get started
[Applause]
[Music]
a vast continent full of riches and a
rapidly expanding population the last
continent to join modernity a land of
infinite opportunities a territory on
which the people's republic of china has
focused its attention and into which it
has poured its capital chinese money and
companies now spread throughout this
continent something that is generating
many concerns in the west over the last
few decades the economic and social
landscape in africa has begun to change
from despair there was a shift to almost
total optimism a fierce and
irrepressible optimism from 2000 to 2018
extreme poverty was reduced by more than
30 percent average life expectancy
increased by more than 10 years and
infant mortality was halved in addition
some economies began to evolve so fast
that they got their own label the
african lions suddenly the last
continent the forgotten continent was
beginning to take off so how could we
not get caught up in the excitement when
at last finally africa was ready to
start the race for modernity hold your
horses though because the sars
coronavirus ii pandemic has dealt a
severe blow and i'm not just talking
about the impact on health
in the midst of all this euphoria
investment projects began to mushroom
across the continent obviously
investment has to be financed but as
africa was growing that was no longer a
problem quite the contrary with interest
rates at rock bottom in developed
countries many agencies and institutions
around the world began to channel more
and more capital flows to africa causing
the continent's external debt to double
in just a few years
it wasn't a problem they could afford it
economies were growing so much that
external debt was not a burden in
relative terms for many countries their
situation apparently even improved but
of course with the impact of the
pandemic that scenario was turned upside
down virtually overnight
[Music]
suddenly africa faced its first
recession since the beginning of the new
century poverty started to rise again
and many governments started to have
serious problems in the face of debt
repayments and not only that the
pandemic itself increased spending
whilst reducing revenues which
multiplied the financial needs of many
states the situation that caused public
debt to rise sharply as you can see on
screen
to make matters worse the rating
agencies downgraded the credit rating of
a lot of countries to the point that
today 93 of african governments assessed
by these agencies are below investment
grade that is their debt is considered
junk bonds which means much less
available money and much more expensive
money
[Music]
we are talking about a debt problem a
problem that could eventually lead to a
financial and economic crisis countries
as prosperous as kenya ethiopia and
cameroon have started to have some
problems in the last decades and this is
where all the alarm bells have gone off
firstly because of the risk of new
humanitarian crises in africa and
secondly because of the geopolitical
risk that this entails because if we're
talking about debt and africa we also
need to be talking about china for
example the united states government
during the time of the trump
administration went so far as to
denounce the perverse use by the
people's republic of china of what is
known as debt trap diplomacy now what
were they getting at and is there any
truth to it how far did china's
intentions go what on earth is the u.s
government even talking about listen up
china's buying up of africa
[Music]
since xi jinping came to power africa
has gained more and more prominence in
chinese diplomacy as president of the
asian giants in addition to promoting
forums and meeting spaces the chinese
leader has made four tours of the
continent so we could say that xi
jinping's presence in africa has been
much greater than that of any other
major international leader and it shows
chinese politics have followed in the
footsteps of china's growing economic
ties with africa or perhaps it was
economics that followed politics which
came first the chicken or the egg the
thing is that since 2000 china's trade
with africa has increased by over 2
thousand percent to reach over 200
billion dollars in 2019 and that is not
all if in 2006 there were 800 chinese
state-owned companies operating on the
african continent today there are more
than 10 000 public and private companies
present which has made china also become
along with the united kingdom and france
the largest investor in the region
[Music]
to give you an idea 40 percent of the
infrastructure market a significant
percentage of mining activity and more
than 12 percent of all industrial
production in africa is already in the
hands of chinese companies
companies like transient the shenzhen
based mobile phone manufacturer that
leads the african market and operates
local factories factories like the one
that opened in 2011 in addis ababa the
capital of ethiopia where it
manufactures more than 1 million mobile
terminals each year
we are talking about an exposure that
just keeps on growing gambles such as
for example the one presented by the
chinese ambassador to nigeria on the
21st of september 2021 when he announced
that the launching of one of china's
largest banks in the african country was
being finalized through the front door
china has chosen nigeria for a specific
reason it's oil nigeria being an opec
member state records its oil sales in
dollars this move is to persuade the
energy sector in nigeria to accept
payments for its oil in yuan arthur dong
professor of strategy and economics at
georgetown university mcdonough school
of business but wait a minute because if
one thing has stood out in recent years
it has been debt you see china has
become the largest foreign lender in all
of africa according to johns hopkins
university's africa china initiative
official borrowing by chinese government
and large state-owned enterprises
totaled more than 150 billion dollars
between 2000 and 2018.
as an example over the past two decades
china has financed one in five
infrastructure projects on the continent
and take note because many of these
loans whose specific terms and
conditions are kept secret at beijing's
express request apparently include
strategic sovereign assets as collateral
or even payment with raw materials this
could be the case in angola for example
the country that has received the most
loans from china by far and the
repayment of which would be made largely
with barrels of oil as we shall see this
could be one of the asian power's main
objectives
[Music]
but regarding the debt to china look at
what uganda's finance minister said in a
2018 letter to president mussovany
given what is happening in our peer
countries as regards to china debt we
strongly believe we should protect our
assets from possible takeover matija
kashija minister of finance of uganda in
2018. so with all this in mind i think
there are a few questions that we need
to ask ourselves what exactly is china
looking for in africa is there a debt
trap and if so what would be the
implications for the african continent
of this whole process we have described
listen up
[Music]
the debt trap
the question the big question i think
we're all wondering is what exactly is
china looking for what price does it
really demand in return for its
financial support and no i'm not
referring to the interest rate in 2017
the trump administration began putting
the idea of the debt trap on the table
according to this theory the chinese
government would basically be promoting
the delivery of official loans to
developing countries with the essential
objective of indebting them up to their
necks in order to control them and be
able to take advantage of them that is
to say to obtain concessions so to see
if this makes sense or not let's change
the question slightly if they are
correct what exactly are the benefits
that china could get okay i think the
first of these is very obvious china
devours raw materials and if africa has
anything it is precisely natural
resources
more than a third of all the oil china
imports and 20 of the cotton consumed by
the chinese textile industry comes from
africa and that's without even
mentioning resources such as manganese
essential for steel production or colton
vital for the electronics industry and
the largest reserves of which are found
precisely in this continent and those
are just four examples in a very long
list
[Music]
in this way the loans could have had a
double function on the one hand to build
the infrastructure that china needs to
be able to exploit all these resources
and on the other hand to trap the
governments in order to control these
very resources but beyond this issue
there's one thing that has stood out
lately and it is political mileage yes
yes that's right the political use of
debt to win support in exchange for
improved loan conditions or extended
repayment terms
[Music]
for example in 2020 of the 53 countries
that signed a statement of support for
china at the un human rights council
after the passing of the national
security law in hong kong 25 were
african and three other major countries
nigeria south africa and kenya although
they did not support the law did not
join in the criticism against beijing
and exactly the same happened with the
denunciations against the persecution of
the weakers and other ethnic minorities
many african countries have supported
china in international organizations
likewise the votes of african countries
are also supporting the election of
chinese representatives to lead
important international institutions as
is the case of the food and agriculture
organization of the united nations led
from 2019 by a representative of the
chinese government thanks in large part
to african votes
[Music]
okay so it's clear that all of this is
happening the debt granted to african
governments gives beijing a huge
negotiating leverage but is this the
whole story africa needs capital it
needs infrastructure it needs investment
and here china could be playing an
important role because the question we
can ask ourselves is has africa improved
or not improved over the last two
decades
[Music]
i don't think there is a deliberate plan
by china to indebt any country at all i
think china is fulfilling a very
important role which is in terms of
infrastructure support akanumbi adesina
president of the african development
bank what's more no matter how much we
talk about the debt trap and no matter
how much we are told by washington we
cannot ignore one reality the people's
republic of china has become africa's
largest lender but by no means the only
one
china controls about 25 of africa's
external debt which is a lot yes but it
also means that the remaining 75 is in
the hands of other countries or agencies
just the world bank and the imf have
close to as much presence in africa's
debt as china it's only zambia djibouti
and the democratic republic of congo
that have the majority of their debt in
chinese hands
[Music]
but let's recap
china is gaining political mileage out
of its growing relations with africa but
apparently africa needs chinese
investments hold on though because there
is another factor to consider not
everything is so straightforward china
funds whatever it wants which is fine
but we need to be clear about that china
funds whatever it wants
[Music]
and you know what maybe the problem lies
in the fact that many of the projects
promoted do not make economic sense
which is exactly what has happened
within china itself for example a 2016
oxford university study found that more
than half of all infrastructure projects
in china over the past 30 years have
underperformed according to this study
only 28 of the projects could be
considered economically interesting put
another way what if the chinese model
doesn't work the chinese government
generates enough resources to waste on
oversized or unnecessary infrastructure
but that is not the case with african
governments perhaps this is an
unintended consequence of china's debt
there needs to be a lot of caution on
this issue
if projects have poor economic returns
it means that they may not be able to
generate enough to repay the debt of
course it doesn't have to be that way
africa needs investment and no one could
have anticipated the impact of the
coronavirus it is clear that foreign
direct investment is better than mere
financing and it is also clear that
beijing will use every tool at its
disposal to gain political advantage
even if it means making deals with
corrupt leaders and signing loans for
questionable purposes but if there is
anyone ultimately responsible it is the
african leaders themselves in any case
let's be optimistic built capital
prevails china is very interested in
africa's prosperity and now everything
points to the fact that we are entering
a cycle of rising commodity prices
[Music]
a cycle that could give the african
continent the resources it needs to
overcome the blow dealt by the pandemic
and return to the growth path it has
been maintaining for the last 20 years i
don't know personally what do you want
me to say maybe there's such a thing as
debt diplomacy but i don't think that we
should exaggerate or look for ghosts
around every corner if the chinese
presence in africa is a concern what
western governments will have to do is
look for ways to improve investment in
this continent and the integration of
african countries into the global
economy but this is just an opinion my
opinion now it's your turn do you think
china is really using debt strictly as a
political weapon what do you think
western powers should do should they
fight back should they counter china's
growing influence in africa leave your
answer below in the comments and as
always if you found this video
interesting don't forget to give it a
like thank you very much to all the
patrons who support us and have made
this video possible take care we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]